hallo herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live ich freue mich dass Ihr dabei seid
und dass ihr mit uns diskutieren werdet
wahrscheinlich habt ihr auf dieses Video
geklickt weil euch die Frage kann mein
Geld mir in diesen Zeiten noch irgendwie
gewinnbringen echt umtreibt mich auch
und bei diesem Thema habe ich mir
tatsächlich Verstärkung dazu geholt
nämlich von ZDF Börsenexperte Frank
Wittmann hi hallo Viktoria freue mich
sehr dass du da bist und hier mit uns
diskutieren wirst
ja ich habe es gerade schon gesagt das
sind schwierige Zeiten in denen wir uns
bewegen die Inflation liegt aktuell
irgendwo um die 10% im Oktober diesen
Jahres lag sie sogar beim Höchstwert
10,4 %. das ist tatsächlich der höchste
Stand seit 1951 ja die Inflation frisst
also unser angespartes Geld auf wie kann
man jetzt das was vielleicht noch übrig
geblieben ist am besten investieren in
ETFs in Aktien vielleicht sogar eine
kryptowährung mit all diesen Fragen
werden wir uns heute beschäftigen ich
habe nicht nur Frank Bethmann bei mir
sondern gleich noch einen anderen Gast
wenn ihr Fragen an die beiden habt oder
einfach eure Fragen eure Meinung eure
Kommentare mit uns teilen wollt dann
könnt ihr das wie immer tun schreibt uns
einfach hier in den Youtube Chat oder
schreibt uns eine Mail an ZDF heute-
live@zdf.de ich freue mich auf eure
Fragen unsere Gäste wahrscheinlich auch
jetzt hat gestern die US-Notenbank Fett
den Leitzins in den USA um 0,5% Punkte
erhöht er liegt da jetzt in einer Spanne
von 4,25 bis 4,5% und jetzt ist heute
die Europäische Zentralbank nachgezogen
und hat den Leitzins bei uns von 2% um
0,5 % Punkte auf 2,5 % erhöht ja und das
hören wir uns jetzt erstmal an
der Europäischen Zentralbank hat heute
beschlossen die drei Leitzinsen der EZB
um 50 Basispunkte anzuheben und wegen
der Entwicklung der Inflation erwarten
wir auch weitere Anhebungen
insbesondere sind wir der Meinung dass
die Zinssätze noch deutlich und stetig
steigen müssen um das mittelfristige
Ziel zu erreichen eine Inflation von
zwei Prozent
ja ich muss einmal noch kurz dazu sagen
wer unsere anderen Gast ist auf dem wir
uns gleich freuen können das ist Saidi
solilato von der Verbraucherseite
finanztip bevor wir aber zu dem kommen
muss ich erstmal dich fragen zu dieser
leitzinsgeschichte du bist ja jetzt
schon ziemlich lange in diesem Business
unterwegs befasst sich mit börsenthemen
jetzt haben wir wieder eine
Leitzinserhöhung der EZB es ist ja nicht
die erste in letzter Zeit hast du sowas
in deiner bisherigen Laufbahn schon mal
erlebt also in diesem rasanten Tempo die
Erhöhungen noch nicht man muss sagen die
leitzen waren auch schon mal höher aber
wenn man Frau Lagarde fast vor einem
Jahr gehört hat dann hat sie eigentlich
für 20 22
Zinsschritte Leitzinserhöhungen
ausgeschlossen und da sieht man schon
wie schnell sich das ändern kann und
jetzt in dieser rasanten Geschwindigkeit
und sie hat ja auch eben angedeutet dass
das noch nicht die letzten Schritte
waren das dann noch weiter auch im
nächsten Jahr kommen werden also so habe
ich auch noch nicht erlebt
ja also wir bewegen uns auf jeden Fall
entspannende Zeiten und wie diese
andauernde Inflation mit der wir gerade
zu kämpfen haben auch mit den Zinsen
Zusammenhängen die uns alle als Sparer
als Kreditnehmerin whatever betreffen
das erklärt uns jetzt Antoine
kuscheligen
Sparer in Deutschland können damit
rechnen dass die Guthaben Zinsen für
Ersparnisse weiter steigen zumindest für
Tagesgeld und Festgeld beim dreijährigen
Festgeld liegen die bestzinsen aktuell
bei mehr als drei Prozent pro Jahr
anders die Entwicklung der Bauzinsen sie
sind bereits deutlich angestiegen im
Januar gab es eine Baufinanzierung noch
für einen Zins von einem Prozent im
November waren es dann bei derselben
Bank schon vier Prozent in den kommenden
Monaten werden die Bauzinsen wohl weiter
steigen das wohl größte Problem für
Sparer und Kreditnehmer die hohe
Inflation also der allgemeine
Preisanstieg aller Güter damit sinkt der
Wert des Geldes das was man vor einem
Jahr für 100 € bekommen hat kostet jetzt
deutlich mehr die Inflationsrate steigt
seit November letzten Jahres in
Deutschland an von rund 5% auf
mittlerweile etwa zehn Prozent
wer Geld anlegt landet wegen der hohen
Inflation unterm Strich häufig im Minus
die Europäische Zentralbank gibt als
Ziel eine Inflationsrate von zwei
Prozent vor weil dieser Wert als passend
gilt für einen stabiles
Wirtschaftswachstum
ja und da ist er schon unser zweiter
Gast herzlich willkommen sei die
solilatou von finanztip schön dass du
bei uns bist
hallo grüß euch hallo ja wie wir jetzt
mit diesen höheren Zinsen umgehen wo man
sein Geld jetzt investieren kann darüber
wollen wir in den nächsten Minuten
sprechen wenn ihr Fragen an die zwei
habt noch mal der Hinweis ihr könnt sie
einfach hier in den Youtube Chat
schreiben oder uns eine Mail schicken
per Mail an ZDF heute - live at zdf.de
und jetzt frage ich erstmal fragen wie
ist denn das bei dir hat diese
inflationslage aktuell deine Anlage
Strategie verändert nee nicht wirklich
also ich habe ein paar Fonds im Depot
und die habe ich auch weiterhin es wäre
ohnehin schlechtes ähm Signal oder eine
schlechte Entscheidung wenn man jetzt in
so eine Krise wo die Kurse fallen wo
vielleicht auch der Wert von solchen
Fonds abnehmen wenn man die dann
verkauft sondern jetzt ist eigentlich
eher der Punkt wo man sagt ruhige Hand
Ruhe bewahren und wir werden auch wieder
bessere Zeiten sehen
okay das klingt ja schon mal gar nicht
so schlecht sei die du bist
Finanzexperte im Netz und hast ja eine
riesen Community die sich damit dir
austauscht über die Finanzwelt wie ist
denn das bei dir haben sich seit dieser
hohen Inflation die Fragen deiner
Community verändert
nee also ich glaube das waren
grundsätzlich kann ich Frank auch nur
zustimmen natürlich jetzt ruhig machen
bei Finanzen immer wieder sagen ja das
nee 18 Strategie in der Anlagestrategie
gerade mit Börsenhandel mit dem
berühmten ETFs das ist halt langfristig
ist und da sollte man sich halt so von
solchen Krisen nicht verunsichern lassen
ich kann das total verstehen ich glaube
das total nachvollziehbar dass man
irgendwie das Gefühl hat sich jetzt
dieses Jahr alles verändert ne erst
recht durch den Kriegen sondern
Inflation kennen wir seit Jahrzehnten
nicht mehr in Deutschland und dann muss
ich doch jetzt auch irgendwie mit meinem
Geld alles ändern aber tatsächlich ist
es nicht so ne also gerade so eine
langfristige Idee zu sagen ich setze
langfristig auf Aktien breit gestreut
gleichzeitig sicherlich ein Teil meines
Geldes jetzt auch über den Tagesgeld und
Festgeld ab das ändert sich halt auch
nicht auch wenn wir mal unruhige Farbe
Wasser erleben so wie es gerade Moment
haben und natürlich nicht ganz klar
Moment in den 10 % Inflation diese
sichere die kriegen es gibt nichts was
wir jetzt gerade 10% oder mehr Rendite
sicher verspricht das muss ich leider
jetzt sozusagen aussetzen auch wenn
gleichzeitig auch die Börse jetzt gerade
nicht so lustig aussehen
wir haben direkt schon eine Frage aus
der Community an euch und zwar fragt
User Steve music auf Youtube inwieweit
können Privatanleger ihr Kapital vor der
Inflation schützen wenn die EZB gewillt
ist durch eine höhere Inflation die
Staatsverschuldung abzumildern ist eine
Rückkehr zur soliden Staatsfinanzierung
in Europa noch möglich Frank was ist
dein Gedanke dazu ja ist ein langer Weg
aber seien wir mal optimistisch dass das
irgendwie noch wieder geht solide
Staatsfinanzen heißt ja auch dass der
Staat nicht überschuldet ist etc pp aber
wenn wir jetzt mal auf die auf die
leitzinspolitik schauen dann ist ja das
oberste Gebot der Währungshüter
eigentlich dass wir wieder runterkommen
mit der Inflation da haben wir heute
auch ein bisschen was gehört dass die
EZB mittlerweile wohl erst 2025 damit
rechnet dass man wieder bei 2% ist und
so eine hohe Inflation die ist natürlich
auch sozial etwas sehr ungerecht ist
weil es Arme wie reiche gleichzeitig
betrifft die Reichen können das ein
bisschen besser aussetzen vielleicht als
die als die ärmeren und insofern ist es
ja schon gut wenn wir irgendwann wieder
runterkommen denn Saidi hat ja eben
schon gesagt also zehn Prozent Rendite
jetzt irgendwo zu erwirtschaften ist
schon schwer also da muss man schon ganz
schöner Zocker sein und das sind wir
hier glaube ich in der Runde nicht und
wenn man solide angeht dann wird man im
Augenblick eben diese zehn Prozent nicht
erwirtschaften aber ich sage dann auch
immer Verluste realverluste realisiere
ich dann ja nur wenn ich auch wirklich
verkaufe wenn ich also ruhig bleibe und
dabei bleibe und auch eine gewisse
Mischung habe dann
eine Strategie habe dass ich also auch
meine Anlage auch ein bisschen verteile
dann ist es nicht ganz so schlimm da
muss man es einfach aussetzen da muss
man jetzt mal durch und ich kann mir
vorstellen wenn hier jüngere auch dabei
sind die haben jetzt vielleicht zum
ersten Mal erleben die sowas haben
vielleicht mal ein zwei Jahren mal ein
ETF gekauft und sind jetzt für die Kurse
abgehen
ruhig bleiben an der Stelle das kommt
auch irgendwann wieder und vor allen
Dingen ist es ja so
mehr noch vielleicht in schlechten
Zeiten wenn du ein Sparplan hast ein ETF
kaufen schlechten Zeiten kaufst du mehr
Anteile gut das ist ganz gut aber noch
wichtiger ist eigentlich dieser
Zinseszinseffekt dass du es
kontinuierlich machst dass du früh genug
anfängst und dann ist das mit den mit
den Krisen auch relativ selten schon
gesagt dass ist eine langfristige
Geschichte
ja frank hat gerade schon angesprochen
ETF ist ein riesen Thema vielleicht
kriegt ihr das auch mit in eurem Umfeld
an der Schule im Studium in der Uni in
der Ausbildung viele junge Menschen
machen sich Gedanken um ihre
Altersvorsorge und ein Thema das dazu
immer wieder auftaucht sind eben diese
sogenannten ETF was für eine Art von
Anlage sich hinter diesen drei
Buchstaben verbirgt das hat sich keinem
mehr für uns angeschaut
ETF das steht für Exchange Traded Fund
also börsengehandelter Fonds ein Fond
ist eine Sammlung verschiedener
Wertpapiere wie zum Beispiel Aktien im
Gegensatz zum aktiv gemanagten Fonds bei
dem ein Manager entscheidet welche
Aktien in die Sammlung aufgenommen und
ausgeschlossen werden wird ein ETF
passiv geführt das bedeutet dass er sich
automatisch an einem indexorientiert
steigt der Index steigt auch der Wert
des Fonds umgekehrt passiert das auch
wenn der Index fällt zum Beispiel am DAX
dieser Index gibt an wie sich die 40
größten Unternehmen in Deutschland
entwickeln steigt der DAX um 3% steigt
auch die Rendite um ca 3%, wenn man in
einen solchen DAX ETF investiert hat so
kann man mit kleinem Geld in viele
Unternehmen gleichzeitig investieren und
streut so das Risiko ETFs gibt es für
spezielle Branchen verschiedene Regionen
aber auch für Rohstoffe oder Immobilien
ja sei die wenn ich jetzt also meine ETF
vor dem Ukraine Krieg vor der hohen
Inflation gekauft habe und mir jetzt
Sorgen mache was muss ich da am besten
tun
am besten nicht nur einmal investieren
weil ich sag mir das psychologisch beste
Mittel gegen seine Krisen ist
tatsächlich ein Sparplan auf einen ETF
na wenn ich mich also dafür entscheide
langfristig in aller Regel
wahrscheinlich für ein Altersvorsorge in
vielen Fällen natürlich gerade bei
jungen Leuten monatlich was von Geld
Seite zu legen wie finde ich das auch
schaffe 10 % 15 % weniger gut manche
schaffen sogar 20% oder mehr das
monatliche in so einem bereitgestellten
am besten weltweit streuenden ETF zu
legen dass das hält mich halt bei der
Stange weil ich habe mich dann einmal zu
diesem Plan zu diesem Sparplan committed
ja und kann mir dann auch so ein
bisschen sagen ach ja jetzt gehen die
Kurse runter dann kaufe ich ja zu
günstigeren Kursen ein das heißt froh
allerdings 200 € die ich da Monat rein
spare bekomme ich etwas mehr ETF Anteile
das ist so ein Anker der mich da im
Sturm sag jetzt mal gerne festhält und
das funktioniert ziemlich gut das hat
auch eine Krise vielen Leuten sehr gut
funktioniert und im Moment ist es glaube
ich auch ein sehr wirksames Mittel
Frank würdest du den zustimmen würde ich
auch so zustimmen also ich habe vor fünf
Jahren als mein Sohn auf die Welt kam
auch so ein ETF MSCI World angelegt da
gehen jeden Monat 100 Euro rein und der
hatte vor der Krise glaube ich so sieben
28 Prozent Plus im Augenblick trotz
Krise sind wir vielleicht immer noch so
bei 15 % plus aber es ist diese
Kontinuität und es ist auch immer so ein
Gedanke ja irgendwo in der auf der Welt
geht immer was du hast irgendwo eine
Krise in Europa dann läuft es vielleicht
in Asien oder in Lateinamerika besser
und so ein breit gestreuter wie es ja
auch gesagt hat und dieser MSCI World
ist einer der einfach hat glaube ich
1500 Firmen auf der Welt drin es gibt
auch noch ein weiteren der hat 6000
Firmen drin ähm also da sind auch immer
Aktien von Unternehmen drin die irgendwo
auch Gewinn machen und deswegen stürzen
solche ETFs meistens nicht so stark ab
jetzt ist ja bei jungen Leuten gerade
total beliebt ETFs oder whatever auf
diesen Neo broke anzukaufen also ich
habe eine App auf meinem Smartphone und
kann dann relativ easy da ein Depot
eröffnen verschiedene Produkte kaufen
was sagst du denn zu diesen neobrokern
ja habe ich auch gemacht ist erstmal
nichts gegen einzuwenden man sollte
schauen was das für Neo Broker ist ja
also da gibt es einige wo auch eine Bank
dahinter steht die haben eine Vollbank
Lizenz das wäre so ein erster Hinweis
wir haben wir erleben ja gerade auch
wieder in anderen Bereichen
krypto-börsen und so weiter wo dann auch
Betrug am Start ist oder eine Insolvenz
oder so die sitzen dann meistens
irgendwo im Ausland und da ist das Geld
was man da vielleicht hat dann auch weg
aber so weit muss es ja nicht gehen man
kann ja im Internet heutzutage vieles
recherchieren und wenn man sieht aha
Mensch da ist eine Bank mit einer
Vollbank Lizenz dahinter dann ist
letztendlich so ein neoproker oder auch
eine App letztendlich auch nur ein
anderer Vertriebsweg wie wie eine Bank
ja
wir haben hier eine Frage von Rainer
Rossmann auf Facebook die vielleicht für
viele ganz interessant ist sei die was
heißt denn eigentlich langfristig wir
sprechen die ganze Zeit von langfristig
aber von wie vielen Jahren sprechen wir
da dass sich das lohnt
ja zunächst mal richtig vielleicht an
der Stelle dass man immer anders mit
Eindruck man sollte irgendwie sein
ganzes Geld ein Akt stecken was
natürlich auch nicht also man sollte
schon ein Teil seines Geldes schon
alleine Notgroschen für den nächsten
Nebenkostenabrechnung dir viel Mietern
im Nacken sitzt trotzdem Strom und
gaspreisbremsen die ist jetzt gibt es da
muss man halt einfach Rücklagen haben
das heißt irgend sowas je nach
anlagefreudigkeit und nach ersparen oder
nach Spanien sondern sicherlich 20 30 %
noch irgendwie sicher angelegt haben
Tagesgeld aber gerade bei jungen Leuten
dazu sagen ich gehe mit 60
70% von meinen ja von meinem Vermögen
jetzt in Aktienmarkt was heißt
langfristig wir beim Finanzamt sagen 15
Jahre das ist so eher der der mindestens
sollte man schon mal warten dann drunter
dann kannst du mir halt passieren dass
zwischendrin meine Börsenkrise kommt und
die kann auch normal erheblich erheblich
schlimmer ausfallen dass das was wir
jetzt gerade haben das muss man auch mal
sagen
auch angesprochen hat wenn man den jetzt
in Euro anschaut
ist der nicht mehr als zehn Prozent
gefallen auf 12 Monate sich ja das ist
ein Verlaub gesagt gar nichts also für
die die sich noch erinnern können so
kurzzeitig werden Corona war immer so
Größenordnung 30% im Minus das hat sich
zwar sehr schnell wieder erholt ja aber
so eine Börsenkrise kann auch mal ein
paar Jährchen andauern aber wenn ich
eben auf 15 und vielleicht 20 25 30
Jahre dann dabei bleibe dann kann ich
doch mit einer sehr ordentlichen Rendite
liegen die dann Achtung in den
allermeisten Fällen auch deutlich
oberhalb Inflationsrate liegt auch wenn
man sich das bei der derzeit 10%
Inflation nicht so gut vorstellen kann
Frank ich glaube es ist noch mal wichtig
zu klären was ist jetzt genau der
Unterschied zwischen dem ETF und Aktien
und dann fragt dazu noch Bernd
Schwarzmann auf Facebook als
Privatanleger machen einzelne Aktien
überhaupt sind
das kommt immer drauf an ich sag mal das
einfachere ist wenn wir hier von
Risikostreuung sprechen sicherlich immer
in Fonds ein ETF da setzt du immer auf
mehrere Aktien und nicht auf eine und es
gibt auch Mischfonds da sind Aktien und
Anleihen drin also man kann das Risiko
dann durchaus auch streuen das spricht
zunächst erstmal für so ein Fond ob es
nun ETF ist oder ein Manager geführter
Fond ähm bei Einzelaktien muss ich mich
einfach ein bisschen mehr mit
beschäftigen auch mit Auseinandersetzen
mit dem Unternehmen da gibt's viele
kennen Größen ich muss dann für mich
irgendwie eine Entscheidung treffen das
ist was wozu stehen kann ja nehmen wir
mal ganz extremes Beispiel vielleicht
kann man mit mineralkonzern oder
Rüstungskonzern gutes Geld verdienen
aber jemand da ne also da will ich keine
Aktien von haben das ist dann vielleicht
eine moralische Ebene das ist auch okay
also ich muss gucken bin ich tech-affin
ja dann hole ich mir vielleicht Hightech
Unternehmen vielleicht sage ich aber
auch weißt du was Lebensmittel oder
pharm Geschichten das braucht man immer
das sind die sogenannten defensiven
Werte die auch in der Krise gut gehen
und dann muss ich mir anschauen die
Branche ja es gibt im übrigen auch
branchenspezifische Fonds die kann ich
dann auch nehmen und wenn ich einzelne
Aktien habe will dann muss ich mir das
genau anschauen da gibt es solche kennen
Größen Kurs gewinnen Verhältnis zum
Beispiel das ist nur ein Aspekt also da
wird der Aktienkurs mit dem Gewinn pro
Aktie
dividiert und dann kommt eine Ziffer bei
raus und bei der Ziffer kann ich denn
sagen kleine Ziffer die Aktie ist ja
unterbewertet hohe Ziffer die Aktie ist
tendenziell schon überbewertet also
teurer aber das sind auch wieder nur
Aspekte also was nützt mir eine Aktie
die unterbewertet ist wo das Unternehmen
vielleicht in zwei oder drei Monaten
insolvent ist was ich jetzt im
Augenblick noch gar nicht weiß
andererseits eine Aktie die jetzt schon
überbewertet ist aber die vielleicht ein
Blockbuster am Start hat also ein
Pharmakonzern wo ich denke da die Räumen
die nächsten zwei drei Jahre noch
ordentlich ab also wir hatten das mit
beyontech zuletzt ja
mag vielleicht wenn sie teuer ist immer
noch nicht zu teuer sein ich muss mir
das genau anschauen und deswegen
erfordert das aus meiner Sicht immer ein
bisschen mehr
Recherche und ein bisschen ich muss mich
da ein bisschen mehr mit beschäftigen
Vorteil vielleicht wenn ich Aktien habe
auch da kann ich natürlich nachschauen
ist das ein Unternehmen was immer gut
Dividende ausschüttet ja es gibt
bestimmte die wir ententitel Konzerne
die seit Jahren schon wirklich hohe
Dividenden ausschütten das sind ja
sozusagen die die Zinsen der Aktien die
neuen Zinsen ähm aber ich muss mir da
wirklich viel Gedanken machen und es ist
ein bisschen schwieriger und vielleicht
am Anfang etwas einfacher mit dem Fond
oder mit dem ETF anzufangen ist
zumindest meine Erfahrung
okay also wir halten mal fest um in
Aktien zu investieren brauchst ein
bisschen mehr Fachwissen als ich
vielleicht einfach ein ETF zu kaufen
indem man einmal im Jahr reinguckt in
die Entwicklung wir haben hier aber
trotzdem noch mal eine Frage zu Aktien
das Thema scheint euch sehr zu
interessieren nämlich von KEK Frage der
fragt auf youtube ist es gerade
überhaupt noch sinnvoll kurz bis
mittelfristig in deutsche Aktien zu
investieren speziell der Film Pleiten
und eine schwächelnde Wirtschaft
momentan speziell ein deutsches Problem
sind sei die was sagst du
mit solchen letztendlichen Länder Wetten
ziemlich vorsichtig also wir sind ja
immer da gibt es immer diesen bias sagt
man kauft die Sachen die erkennt ja ob
das jetzt adidas ist oder SAP oder wer
auch immer ja das ist diesen Namen die
man an die einem was sagen anstatt jetzt
in sowas fremdes mal die fremdes wie ein
MSCI World zu schicken also zunächst mal
sagen
wenn man sich da die größten Aktien drin
anschaut dann kommen die dann doch
bekannt vorne diesmal Apple und
Microsoft und Tesla und die ganzen
Kandidaten also das sind davon auch
bekannte Sachen die wir auch im Alltag
durchaus kennen also so fremd ist das
nicht und außerdem muss man sehen wenn
Sie sich jetzt auf den deutschen
Aktienmarkt konzentriert egal ob jetzt
mit einzelnen wo ich sehr sehr
vorsichtig wäre oder auch mit dem Dax ja
das sind vielen Fällen tatsächlich nur
ihre ja höheres Risiko darstellt
natürlich damit auch höhere
Gewinnchancen das ist immer so Risiko
und gewünscht
aber es ist nicht so dass man irgendwie
sagen kann Deutschland deswegen sicherer
Hafen immer nur heute als Beispiel
[Musik]
ja wir wollten schlechten Börsentag
gehabt na der MSCI World ist umso gut
gute zwei Prozent 2,2% etwa in die Tiefe
gegangen in Euro gerechnet aber der
Daxner erhalten -3% je nachdem wo man
jetzt den Schlusspunkt ansetzt ansonsten
typisches Beispiel dass der DAX nehmen
viele Deutsche nicht so wahr ja relativ
risikoreiches Investment ist im
Vergleich mit einer weltweit gestreuten
Investments halt auch nur 40 Akt
mehrere tausend Aktien
drin ja und vielleicht auch noch
ergänzen das ändert sich auch immer
alles ganz schnell wir hatten vor einem
Jahr mit Blick auf 20 20 22 keiner hatte
irgendwie einen Krieg auf der Rechnung
haben durch die Bank weg die Banken
empfohlen europäische deutsche Titel
sind unterbewertet Amerika war stark
gelaufen also war die Empfehlung
eigentlich zum Jahresanfang um Schichten
in unterbewertete Regionen und Titel so
dann kam der Krieg und alles änderte
sich wieder schlagartig also schon acht
Wochen später hat das keiner mehr gesagt
wir sind jetzt auch in einer Situation
wo Deutschland europäische Aktien etwa
30% unterbewertet sind man kann also
darüber nachdenken ob das vielleicht
Kaufkurse sind aber man muss eben wie es
wenn auch schon ausgeführt hat immer
auch überlegen wo sind die besseren
Perspektiven weil kauft ja auch ein
bisschen Zukunft da ein also das heißt
noch nicht immer unbedingt was wenn
etwas unter bewertet ist ja sondern muss
auch gucken ja wie sehen die
wachstumsschancen in Deutschland in
Europa aus wie vergleichsweise aus also
das muss man alles immer ein bisschen
abwägen
ja also ihr seht für ETFs und für Aktien
brauchst du ein ganz
bisschen viele glaube ich auch so ein
sehr abstraktes Thema das nächste Thema
über das Versprechen wollen das ist gar
nicht so abstrakten es gibt ein ganz für
mich erstaunlichen Buben bei jungen
Leuten nämlich Immobilienkäufe als
Wertanlage und wenn man so einigen
influencer im Internet Glauben schenkt
dann ist das eigentlich auch alles mega
easy denn die sagen man kann sich
eigentlich ohne Eigenkapital eine
Immobilie kaufen und dann diesen Kredit
auch abbezahlen durch Mieter und
Mieterin die diesen Kredit abbezahlen ob
das wirklich so easy ist das hat sich
Christian Volk mal für uns angeschaut
bist du eigentlich dass man nicht nur
Immobilien ohne Eigenkapital kaufen kann
sondern ganze Unternehmen das ist
Tomislav primoratsch Immobilien
influencer fast 900.000 Follower allein
auf tiktok das Video ist knapp vier
Wochen alt Immobilien ohne Eigenkapital
ganz beiläufig erwähnt in Wirklichkeit
ist das komplizierter das weiß auch
primoratsch ich schmeiße bei meinen
Videos auch immer ein Stück weit nur
Fetzen rein damit man sich das so ein
herleiten kann wovon ich spreche das
kannst du in 60 Sekunden so lange wie
die wheels oder tiktors gehen gar nicht
alles reinschmeißen und das sind ja
immer nur Informationen also kleine
Impulse die ich beide gebe wo man sich
im Nachgang noch viel viel mehr
informieren muss neben primoratsch gibt
es dutzende weitere große Immobilien und
finanzinfluenza Ihre Zielgruppe ist jung
die meisten Follower kennen sich bisher
nicht aus mit Verträgen steuern oder
Quadratmeterpreisen das Versprechen
kauft eine Wohnung die Miete finanziert
den Kredit Risiken sprechen viele
influencer nicht an warnt die
Verbraucherzentrale
als Eigentümer und auch als Vermieter
einer Immobilie bin ich natürlich für
den Zustand der Immobilie verantwortlich
das heißt wenn Reparaturen anfallen muss
ich die bezahlen wenn ich zum Beispiel
auch über einen gewissen Zeitraum einen
Leerstand habe den ich nicht pompt
vermietet bekomme ein halbes Jahr zum
Beispiel dann muss ich eben die
Kreditrate aus eigenen Mitteln
finanzieren auch die Finanzaufsicht
zieht Anlagetipps auf Social Media
kritisch es gäbe dort zwar seriöse Infos
aber auch viele falsch Darstellungen
influencer die sich zu Finanzprodukten
äußern kennen sich häufig selbst nicht
wirklich gut genug damit aus sie
suggerieren ihren Followern aber das
Gegenteil und setzen auch auf deren
Angst möglicherweise einen Trend zu
verpassen am Ende da sind sich
Verbraucherschützer Finanzexperten und
influencer einig gilt bei allen Finanz-
und immobilientipps auf Social Media
eigene Recherche mehrere Quellen und
selbst dann gibt es noch immer ein
Risiko
ja wir haben es gehört ist vielleicht
gar nicht so einfach wie einem das Leute
im Internet manchmal erzählen weil die
was muss denn gegeben sein oder gibt es
überhaupt eine Möglichkeit dass ich als
junger Mensch verantwortungsvoll eine
Immobilie als Wertanlage kaufe also was
für Kriterien muss ich da vielleicht
erfüllen
also das wichtigste glaube ich dass man
so mitbringt ich muss ein bisschen der
Typ das sein also es ist tatsächlich
eine sagen wir mal ne es geht nicht ohne
Eigenkapital das muss man auch mal ganz
klar sagen und das sollte nicht ohne
Eigenkapital gemacht werden ja zumindest
mal die diversen Steuern und Gebühren
die dann beim Kauf anfallen das werde
ich in aller Regel aus eigener Tasche
zahlen müssen und das sind ganz schnell
warm 10.000 Euro und dafür brauche ich
schon mal ein Kapital an der Stelle sich
natürlich die Frage ist wirklich eine
Immobilie oder das ist schon eine
Alternative das vorhin gesagt haben
langfristig in Aktienmarkt und das ist
dann irgendwie auch pflegeleicht so ein
ETF dagegen bei der Immobilie muss mich
halt kümmern wie schon gehört gerade den
Beitrag gesagt muss gut recherchieren
denn
Einkaufen gewinnen ja das geht auch
immer noch und dann muss ich mich darum
kümmern nein reparieren ich muss den
Stand halten ich muss mich immer wieder
mal vielleicht um 9 Uhr
Eigentumswohnung geht zu Vermietung hat
das alles so Sachen wo ich einfach nicht
damit beschäftigen muss mich auch ein
Stück weit nach hinten dafür haben muss
weil vieles kann man vielleicht auch
selbst machen wenn man Händchen dafür
hat und das ist alles nicht so einfach
wie das Leben gesagt im Internet ganz
normalen suggeriert worden das heißt es
ist vor allen Dingen so eine Lebensstil
Sache denn ich auch wenn ich vielleicht
weiter weg wohne dann muss ich da öfter
mal hinfahren das sind also Sachen die
werden bei angesichts der Renditen
wieder öfter mal versprochen werden auch
der Zugewinne die in den letzten mal
zehn zwölf Jahren am deutschen
Immobilienmarkt drin waren sogar so
geredet und die sind für die Zukunft
halt überhaupt nicht garantiert im
Gegenteil der Leben glaube ich gerade in
der Phase wo die Immobilienpreise
wahrscheinlich vorsichtig mal gesagt
nicht mehr stark steigen Stück weiter
zurückgekommen das ist angesichts dessen
also stark gestiegen sind lästern die
Nachfrage nach weil die Leute sich die
Finanzierung also sprich die nicht mehr
so leicht leisten können
und wir haben eine
unterbrechen und noch vielleicht
ergänzend irgendwann läuft der 100%
fremdfinanzierte Kredit ja auch aus und
dann muss ich eine Anschlussfinanzierung
haben weil ich in aller Regel das Objekt
dann nämlich noch nicht abbezahlt habe
und in Zeiten jetzt wo die Zinsen
steigen könnte das sehr schnell teurer
werden insofern kann ich alles nur
unterstützen und vielleicht man hat
früher immer mal so gesagt 20%
Eigenkapital sollten sein 80%
Fremdfinanzierung als die Zinsen jetzt
ganz weit unten waren mögen Banken und
auch immer vielleicht mutiger gewesen
sein aber ich würde in der Regel immer
sagen also 20% sollte man schon als
Eigenkapital versuchen mitzubringen
wir haben zu dem Thema auch eine Frage
aus der Community von Dennis der fragt
wir sind eine junge Familie um die 30
und planen in ca 5 Jahren die
Anschaffung einer Immobilie wie sollte
man das Ersparte also schon mal gut also
ein Kapital am besten zwischenlagern und
weiter sparen Frank was denkst du
naja wenn ich es dann auf jeden Fall
zielgerichtet brauche würde ich jetzt
vielleicht mal nach und nach wer jetzt
mein erster Gedanke mal gucken was es
auf dem Festgeldkonten gibt ja also da
würde ich jetzt aber auch noch nicht
alles drauf legen weil wir haben ja
gehört die Leitzinsen werden
wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen weiter
steigen das heißt ich schaue mal nach
vorne und sag mal im Frühjahr ist noch
mal nächsten Jahres könnte es vielleicht
noch ein bisschen höhere Zinsen geben
eine andere Möglichkeit wäre
möglicherweise auch schon mal anzufangen
Bausparvertrag wir erleben ja gerade
sozusagen die Renaissance des
Bausparvertrages wo ich mir zumindestens
auch eine gewisse ist ein gewisses
Zinsniveau jetzt sichern kann ja also
wenn ich auch davon ausgehe dass die
Hypothekenzinsen vielleicht noch ein
bisschen weiter steigen werden das wären
so zwei Gedanken die ich jetzt spontan
habe vielleicht hat sie noch was zu mir
ergänzen
ja ich bin bestimmt nur teilweise zu den
Bausparvertrag wäre ich ziemlich
vorsichtig muss ich ganz klar sagen weil
zum einen was man sehen muss beim
baustauftrag ist eine Wette ja das
glaubt immer gar keine konservatives
Produkt wie ein bauchvertrag ist eine
Wette darauf dass die Zinsen dann wenn
ich ihn brauche zum Beispiel fünf Jahren
deutlich hören warum deutlich höher weil
zum einen kostenvertrag Gebühren das
bleibt nicht aus und zum anderen sind
halt die anspannen also das was ich da
jetzt ein zahle dass da kommt sind nach
ziemlich niedrig da bin ich tatsächlich
in vielen Fällen derzeit beim Festgeld
besser aufgestellt dass man bei
finanztip mal durchgerechnet und da
müssen die Zinsen in fünf z.B in fünf
Jahren schon deutlich also recht extrem
viel höher liegen damit sich zumindest
die derzeitigen Angebote weil Bausparen
wirklich lohnen also da würde ich eher
den Plan mit dem Festgeld zustimmen und
ersetzen möchte sagen was nicht machen
sollte aufeinander Ansicht von 5 Jahren
ist tatsächlich Aktien anzulegen aber
das kann Gewalt geben gerade wenn es ein
Kapital vielleicht nicht so reichlich
ist da und dann bei den heutigen
Immobilienpreisen da gibt's schon mal
schnell und 1000 € hin oder her das
da kann ich es mir nicht riskieren
sozusagen das sind fünf Jahren die
Aktienkurse niedriger stehen als heute
was durchaus passieren kann also da muss
man wirklich ganz konservativ anlegen
auch wenn man sich denkt lege ich
irgendwie für zwei zweieinhalb drei
Prozent an und haben wir haben gerade 10
% Inflation ja was Island es ist leider
so und deswegen ist es dann auch wichtig
hinter dem immobilienplan unbedingt zu
bleiben weil das sollte sich halt nicht
länger Hinsehen also aus den fünf Jahren
sollten nicht 10 Jahre werden wo das
Geld auf dem Festgeld ich sag mal
deutlich versaut
ja also wir sehen auch bei dem Thema
gibt es vielleicht nicht die eine
goldene Lösung die sind sehr
individuelle Entscheidung immer selber
auch passen was man für ein Gefühl hat
wie Risiko affin oder Risiko bereit man
ist aber auf jeden Fall kann ich nur
unterstützen wenn ich ein Ziel habe ich
brauche das Geld in drei vier oder fünf
Jahren dann nicht in Aktien ich glaube
da sind wir uns alle einig Aktien
langfristig eine gute Sache aber
kurzfristig mit Ziel immer gucken dass
das Geld halt wie sicher bleibt ja und
die fest sind fest sind sind im
Augenblick leider nicht so hoch aber man
kann natürlich nur hoffen dass die
Inflation auch langsam wieder ein
bisschen runterkommen ja das wäre dann
auch noch ein guter Effekt
frank hat gerade schon angesprochen
Thema Risikobereitschaft das ist bei
Geld auf jeden Fall auch ein wichtiges
Thema und wenn wir schon dabei bleiben
was junge Menschen und
zum Thema Geld gerade im Internet zu
bewegen dann kommt man an einem Bereich
nicht vorbei nämlich an den
kryptowährungen Bitcoin Eva habt ihr
bestimmt alles schon mal gehört da gab
es ja zeitweise um 2017 rum auch mal so
einen richtigen Krypto Boom das sieht
mittlerweile anders aus uns hat man
interessiert ob ihr da draußen
eigentlich ein Krypto investiert und da
hat kein Riemen mal für uns nachgefragt
also der Krypto ist nur ganz kleiner
Teil ansonsten gibt's ja Immobilien und
normale Fonds noch halt mit Standard
werden also kryptus nur der kleine Teil
tatsächlich ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass es eine Generation Frage ist und
damit habe ich mich noch nicht
auseinandergesetzt und dann besteht eine
gewisse Unsicherheit und wenn sie
Unsicherheit besteht sollte man also ich
zumindest für mich lass die Finger davon
am Anfang hatte ich schon mal gemacht
ja damals musste ich noch in Dänemark
Einkaufen quasi und hatte noch eine
Wallet mittlerweile finde ich das schon
viel Schuld dabei man sieht viel dass
die Leute unglaublich reich geworden
sind ja und wahrscheinlich hat mich das
einfach gelockt ich hatte mal kurz ein
paar Bitcoin also so Anteile von ist
keine ganzen und
dabei ich glaube das ist was warum man
schon relativ viel Zeit rein investieren
muss weil man ja eigentlich immer up to
date sein muss was gerade abgeht ich
glaube das ist ein heißer Markt
vielleicht hat man den Absprache den den
den Sprung oder wie nennt sich das den
Anfang damals nicht geschafft ich weiß
nicht ob es jetzt zu spät ist auf jeden
Fall sollte man es weiter beobachten
muss
ja die Leute haben dazu ganz
verschiedene Meinung alle sind sich
einig aber dass man da auf jeden Fall
ein bisschen Zeit investieren muss um
sich zu belesen fragen wie
empfehlenswert sind denn gerade
Investitionen kryptowährungen in unserer
Zeit der Inflation na das ist nun
wirklich was für Leute die bereit sind
Risiko zu gehen wir haben das ja in den
letzten Jahren erlebt da sind ja riesen
Ausschläge das hat im wesentlichen
eigentlich auch dazu geführt dass sich
institutionelle Anleger eigentlich aus
dem kryptomarkt weitestgehend raushalten
in den super spitzen vielleicht mal drin
waren wir haben das dann gesehen mit
Beginn des Krieges sind die Kurse dann
ja deutlich abgesagt wir haben vorhin
beim MSCI World von -10%. ich glaube
bitcoin ist -60%, mittlerweile gefallen
und ähm das muss man schon aushalten
können
da locken immer wahnsinnige
Gewinnspannen aber es ist auch ein
großes Risiko keiner weiß im Augenblick
wo die Reise hingeht
mehr noch als bei anderen Themen gilt da
muss ich mich wirklich mit beschäftigen
ich habe vor drei vier Jahren über
Bitcoin die dahinter liegende
Technologie auch ein Film gemacht er hat
mich damals sehr dafür interessiert und
auch begeistert und die dahinterliegende
Technologie diese blockchain die die ist
ja auch was wirklich gutes also man
konnte damals immer sagen digitale
Währung für eine digitale Wirtschaft
irgendwie passt das ja zusammen aber das
hat noch nichts damit zu tun dass ich
jetzt sage bitcoin ist eine ist eine
super Assetklasse ich will da nicht
dagegen reden das ist wirklich auch eine
mentalitätssache aber allen die
sozusagen an den Anfang stehen muss man
einfach für den Risiken waren und im
übrigen ist das ganze ja mal gestartet
als eine Währung von den Leuten die
etwas machen wollten gegen das ist der
blind oder etwas wo sozusagen der Staat
nicht mit hinein regieren kann jetzt
reden wir auf einmal oder seit vielen
Jahren schon kann ich damit gewinnen
machen ist das eine Anlageklasse das
muss man glaube wirklich sehr fein
unterscheiden und die Entwicklungen
werden weitergehen also auch was man mit
digitalen Währungen was man für Daten
mit draufschreiben kann also Smart
contracts ist da das Stichwort dass man
also mit einem Zahlungsausgleich auch
sozusagen Leistungen verbinden kann
da war immer so das Beispiel also ich
bräuchte dann später beim Hauskauf
beispielsweise den Notar nicht mehr ja
der absichert dass das Geld dann auch
auf meinem Konto ist wenn ich das Haus
übergebe sondern dass das sozusagen auf
der
kryptowährung dann mit drauf geschrieben
ist aber ich glaube diese Entwicklung
werden noch weitergehen und mich
erinnert das immer so ein bisschen an
die New Economy damals wo also auch so
High Flyer waren wie Intershop die
gesagt haben das Internet damals wird
die Welt verändern stimmt das hat die
Welt verändert aber es ist am Ende nicht
Intershop gewesen sondern ich sage jetzt
mal Amazon ja und so kann ich mir das
mit kryptowährungen auch vorstellen ja
so muss man sauber unterscheiden
mein Blick
ist um die zwei größten kryptowährungen
seit Januar 2020 so abgegangen ist
angefangen mit Bitcoin dort sieht man
dass der Kurs in den Jahren 2020 und
2021 förmlich explodiert ist es aber
auch immer wieder starke Schwankungen
gab zwischendurch im November 2021 lag
der Wert eines Bitcoins bei gut 56.000 €
aktuell liegt der bei etwa 16.800 € auf
Platz zwei der Top kryptowährungen liegt
Eva der vielleicht auch schon mal gehört
der aktuelle Wert zeigt wie viel
Investoren und Käufer bereit sind dafür
zu zahlen aktuell ist ein ifair war 1250
€ zu haben
ja sei die wärmes gehört das ist
vielleicht auch eine Typ Sache wem
würdest du denn Investitionen in
kryptowährung empfehlen oder würdest du
es überhaupt empfehlen
pauschal würde ich nicht empfehlen
Franke schon gesagt hat ich glaube das
ist das ganze Thema kryptowährungen
trifft auf eine Generation die natürlich
erstens digital aufgewachsen ist und
auch sehr technikaffin ist und da
herrschte Begeisterung dafür davor das
kann ich auch total verstehen das macht
ja auch Spaß sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen da neues Universum
für sich zu ähm erschließen aber diese
Begeisterung sozusagen mit großen
Gewinnchancen zu vermengen das ist halt
die Gefahr aber dann liegt auf einmal in
mir so hier und das ist glaube ich was
ganz wichtiges auf sich selbst zu hören
wenn auf einmal so Dollarzeichen in den
Augen und den Bauch zu groß werden sein
wenn man sich denken oh das ist so toll
das muss ja dann ist wahrscheinlich
dabei ein Haken dran und das findet man
halt im Internet auch wieder vom
diversen Influenza immer wieder ich
glaube das ist ganz wichtig auch schon
geschrieben hatte wenn ich ins Zimmer
reingehe immer auf ja Anwendungen einer
Technologie eine Technologie gesagt hat
sehr vielversprechend ist der ja
vielseitig eingesetzt werden kann
Technologie aber jede Strukturierung an
sich auch der bitcoin ist letztendlich
nur eine Anwendung auf dieser
Technologie und die mag sich durchsetzen
aber muss ich durchsetzen solche Sätze
kriege ich dann damit ziemlich viele
hate ja weil sehr viele
bitcoin-anhänger gibt die sagen
natürlich das ist das das kommt Ding
aber das muss halt nicht sein ja es kann
sich auch eine andere kryptowährung
langfristig durchsetzen oder sogar gar
keine das heißt ich kann das jetzt nicht
nur denjenigen empfehlen die ja bisschen
Geld zum Spielen
sagen immer so maximal vielleicht 5 %
von dem was ich so zum Anlegen habe das
kann ich dann schon mal da in Bitcoin
oder in andere kryptowährungen
investieren muss aber bereit sein ja das
geht jedenfalls auch komplett
abzuschreiben wenn das irgendwie ja in
10 Jahren weißt du noch damals das mit
Bitcoin haha und so weiter aber es macht
natürlich auch ganz anders sein und dann
hat man einen großen einfach gemacht
aber da jetzt solides Investment
draufzusetzen im Sinne von irgendwie
auch nur Teil meiner Altersvorsorge da
rein zu investieren auf gar keinen Fall
ja wir haben hier auch Meinungen aus der
Community hier sagt Finanzen für
Anfänger auch ein Youtuber zu dem Thema
Krypto ist hoch spekulativ kann man
machen ist aber keine Anlagestrategie
wenn dann mischt Krypto nur wenn dann
sollte man dazu mischen alles andere ist
Wahnsinn und der YouTube User Thor 643
fragt welche kryptowährungen existieren
in eurer Meinung nach noch in zehn
Jahren kann man das sagen
ganz schwer zu sagen ich nehme mich
jetzt mal aus dem Fenster und sage also
die die beiden großen wahrscheinlich ja
Bitcoin und Eva
eva hat von der Entwicklung der
Architektur in letzter Zeit mehr gemacht
es gab immer auch das Thema dass das
sehr umweltschädlich ist dieses ähm
schürfen von von Bitcoins und bei Isa
ist es hat ein Update gegeben das ist ja
alles jetzt ein bisschen
umweltfreundlicher klimafreundlicher ist
ein paar andere Funktion noch drauf also
da hat man einen Schritt macht der
könnte später noch mal interessant
werden aber
ich glaube es gibt im Augenblick 7000
etwa verschiedene kryptowährungen es ist
schwer zu sagen wer sich dadurch setze
ich würde da vom Bauchgefühl einfach
sagen ja die größten wahrscheinlich noch
am längsten
ja und die
ja gerne
also existieren wahrscheinlich schon
relativ viele die heute Fragezeichen
ja ihr seht also diese ganze kryptowelt
ist eine sehr bewegte Welt bei der man
nicht so richtig viel sicher vorhersagen
kann also jetzt ist die kryptowelt
gerade in den letzten Tagen Wochen von
einem großen Skandal erschüttert worden
wo wir euch auch noch mal was
vorbereitet haben
das ist in der
volksgeschichten sondern auch Pleiten
gibt es halt FTX FTX ist eine insolvente
Handelsplattform über die Nutzer unter
anderem mit kryptowährungen wie Bitcoin
und Isa handeln konnten ftx-gründer
bankman Fried steht im Verdacht
Investorengelder in Milliarden Höhe von
unkreuz zu haben er wurde verhaftet
ja da fragen sich also gerade ganz viele
Menschen die da rein investiert haben wo
dieses Geld ist und viel davon müssen
wir wahrscheinlich sagen ist weg
wir gucken noch mal hier in die
Community es gibt ganz viele Fragen zu
dem Thema das also dieses Thema Finanzen
scheint euch sehr umzutreiben
was würdest du sagen Frank wie wird sich
die kryptus hin in den nächsten Jahren
entwickeln
ja wir haben ja eben schon so ein
bisschen über die Währung gesprochen
was wir erleben werden ist sicherlich
dass die ich nenne das jetzt mal die
etablierten Währungen sind ja alle
irgendwo auch dabei am entwickeln eine
digitale Versionen rauszubringen ja in
Schweden wird schon sehr lange an der
digitalen Krone gearbeitet die Chinesen
arbeiten da dran auch in Deutschland und
Europa macht man sich Gedanken über
einen digitalen Euro ob das alles mal so
kommen wird keine Ahnung aber es wird
dieses Thema sicherlich weiter befeuern
und ähm was das Thema Krypto Börsen
anbelangt wir haben es eben in dem einen
Beitrag schon gehört man kann ja
kryptowährungen mittlerweile auch bei
Neo Brokern oder oder anderen auch
kaufen also ich muss nicht unbedingt auf
einer krypto-börse handeln wenn ich das
dann tue sollte ich aber immer schauen
wer steht denn eigentlich dahinter das
haben wir vorhin auch schon gesagt und
insofern ja wenn ich dann nicht
irgendwie eine Einlagen Versicherung
habe dann ist das wie bei FTX sicherlich
vermutlich weg und es ist gewissermaßen
gerade bei uns Deutschen ist das Thema
ja immer sehr stark mit Vertrauen
verbunden und das ist dann immer so ein
Schlag ins Kontor haben wir bei Aktien
mit Wirecard vor zwei drei Jahren auch
gehabt und sowas tut dann immer dem
Thema Geldanlage insgesamt nicht gut man
wird vorsichtiger wobei ich auch gelesen
habe dass gerade deutsche sich sehr
stark mit diesem Thema Bitcoin und so
weiter auseinandersetzen und das
offensichtlich sehr spannend finden ob
das ein gutes Zeichen ist kann ich nicht
sagen dass
das darf dann jeder interpretieren aber
es ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema von
großen Interesse und das scheint sie ja
auch heute zu bestätigen
ja wir haben hier noch mal ein ganz
anderes Thema aus der Community zu dem
wir uns sicher auch was sagen könnt
vielleicht hat es auch mit einem
gewissen Vertrauensverlust zu tun den du
gerade angesprochen hast es geht hier
nämlich etwa nur etwas sehr altes
nämlich um Edelmetalle Gold Silber etc
YouTube User music Freak sagt der kleine
Mann sollte lieber in Edelmetalle
investieren und dazu passend die Frage
von
selbsthilator rolls ich hoffe ich habe
das richtig ausgesprochen der fragt auch
auf YouTube Edelmetall Sparpläne
sinnvoll oder kann das weg sei die was
denkst du
also grundsätzlich zum Thema edelmetable
zum Thema Gold Gold ist keine Geldanlage
und so hat funktioniert das jetzt gerade
mal provokant das Geld ist eine
Absicherung oder man könnte auch sagen
eine Versicherung das heißt ich kann
schon insbesondere wenn ich schon ja
gibt es mögen aufgebaut habe den Teil in
physischen Gold also tatsächlich müssen
sowas wie Krügerrand oder sowas anlegen
wir sagen bei Finanzamt generell so ja
bis zu 10 %, und das eben als
Absicherung dass ich wirklich in eine
schwere Krise rein und meiner schweren
Krise war nicht also sowas wie eine
schwere Wirtschaftskrise eine
Währungskrise und dann zu sagen ich habe
hier etwas hoffentlich dann
wertbeständiges bzw dass meine
Goldmünzen letztendlich bis dann sehr
viel mehr wert geworden sind und die
kann ich dann wahrscheinlich hoffentlich
in eine neue Währung umtauschen einfach
darauf beruht auf der Erfahrung das halt
seit Jahrtausenden Deutschen immer ja
den Menschen was wert gewesen ist als
Sparplan kann ich das machen aber ich
muss dann sehr genau schauen wie wird
das eigentlich angelegt wird das auch
ist das mit physischen Gold hinterlegt
das würde ich immer als ähm ja als
Bedingungen sozusagen machen dass dort
wirklich einen vertrauenswürdige
Anbieter ist der das aus physisches Gold
gelegt und nicht in irgendwelche
Zertifikate oder
sonstigen der Papiere und im
Zweifelsfall das ist die einfach immer
die sichere Methode weil ich mich ja auf
eine schwere Krise einstellen will ist
das Geld was ich ihm in Gold investieren
möchte zur Seite zu legen wir davon den
regelmäßigen Abständen dann sozusagen
vielleicht eine Münze pro Jahr oder
sowas in Richtung wenn ich das schaffe
zu kaufen denn noch mal es ist ja das
ist die Philosoph bei uns auch Zeit sich
einzustellen vielleicht verschiedene
Sachen auch nicht funktionieren und dann
mich darauf zu verlieren lassen dass
derjenige anbietet das Gold vielleicht
auch tatsächlich physisch angelegt hat
ja mir das dann liefert weil ich das an
der Krise brauche da würde ich mich eher
nicht noch verlassen da habe ich lieber
bei mir
also ich bin auch ein großer oder ich
bin ein großer Freund von von Gold würde
es immer beimischen visaidi schon sagt
aber immer nur physisch es gibt diese
gold-zertifikate da will ich auch
niemanden was Schlechtes bei reden aber
du musst dann am Ende des Tages auch
wissen wer steht dahinter der
Herausgeber der Papiere hatte das
ordentlich mit Gold hinterlegt oder hat
das eben nicht ähm vor zwei drei Jahren
etwa war der stand dass es eigentlich
mehr Gold Zertifikate gibt als es
physisches Gold gibt da muss also
irgendwas nicht stimmen und insofern
habe ich das auch in der Tat immer
lieber gerne in der Hand und entweder
ein Krügerrand oder eine kleine Feinunze
oder sowas das was man sich ein
kleineren Stückelungen leisten kann und
dann eben als Beimischung und ja da wird
auch der ein oder andere jetzt sagen gut
ich brauche dann auch noch einen kleinen
tresorplatz oder vielleicht eine kleine
schließt was das sind Kosten aber das
würde ich mir an der Stelle sagen das
gönn ich mir auch aus Sicherheitsgründen
weil Gold ist auch immer ein guter Idee
hat schon gesagt echt ein guter guter
Absicherung
ja ihr seht ist ein ganz vielfältiges
Thema und ich hoffe dass ihr jetzt zum
Thema investieren in der Krise wenn es
denn für euch möglich ist ein bisschen
schlauer seid als vorher ich bin es auf
jeden Fall vielen Dank Frank vielen Dank
sei die dass ihr da wart danke für eure
Fragen und Kommentare zum Thema ich
hoffe wir sehen uns bald wieder bei ZDF
heute live und euch noch einen schönen
Abend ciao ciao tschüss